vous souvenez dans la vidéo sur
l'épilepsie et les jeux vidéo je vous
avais dit qu'on allait en reparler de la
pls ben voilà c'est aujourd'hui
doug ross cécilia reyes gregory house
michaela quinn perec shepherd elliot
reid
quel est leur secret pour être si sexy
il sauve des vies ça vous fait une bonne
raison d' apprendre à sauver défi
l'autre raison c'est apprendre à sauver
des vies
ça peut sauver des vies
la céleste est pas une technique d'une
médiation c'est la position latérale de
sécurité
c'est la position dans laquelle on doit
placer quelqu'un qui respire mais qui
est inconscient pour éviter qu'ils
s'étouffent avec la langue par exemple
ou avec son genou ou avec un petit
animal qui viendraient creuser son
terrier dans l'arrière gorge de la
victime qui en réalité on n'avale pas sa
langue comme on l'entend dire souvent
quand une personne est inconsciente ou
ses muscles se relâchent et si elle est
allongée sur le dos la langue tombe en
arrière et bien bouché les voies
respiratoires
le problème c'est quand une victime est
inconsciente elle perd un certain nombre
de réflexes comme celui d'avaler ce
qu'elle a dans la bouche pour tousser
pour libérer ses voies respiratoires
donc il faut le faire à sa place pour
lui sauver la vie ce sera quand même
plus parlant avec une petite
démonstration mais pour ça il va me
falloir un mannequin qui se courent ici
je
mannequin pas genre adriana karembeu
mannequin genre mannequin de secourisme
maintenant il à poil un exact moi je
veux garder quand même mon slip les gens
allaient d'accord cette personne est
inconsciente je suis totalement
inconscient alors qu'est-ce que je peux
faire
la première chose à faire c'est de vous
assurer que la victime est bien
consciente et pas juste en train de
faire une petite sieste pour sa adressez
vous directement à elle et donnez lui un
ordre simple messieurs vous l'entendez
ouvrez les yeux
ces rémois la main si vous n'obtenez
aucune réponse la victime bien
inconsciente il faut prévenir les
secours
demandez à quelqu'un de faire le 15 pour
joindre le samu ou le 18 pour appeler
les pompiers
de toute façon ils communiquent entre
eux et ils vous enverront l'équipe la
plus adaptée à la situation si vous êtes
tout seul
appelée à l'aide en commençant à vous
occuper de la victime à l'aide commence
à vous occuper de la victime à l'aide
ensuite occupez vous de tout ce qui peut
gêner la respiration enlever les
premiers bouton du pantalon desserrer la
ceinture le col de la chemise ou du
chemisier la cravate le foulard et ses
potes tu laisses je respire très bien
avec avec la paume de votre main appuyée
sur le front et glisser deux ou trois
doigts de l'autre main sous le menton
basculer délicatement la tête en arrière
la langue se décolle et libère les voies
aériennes mais il faut vérifier qu'il
n'ya rien d'autre qui les bloque
ouvrez la bouche de la victime ait
retiré les corps étrangers qu'il ya à
l'intérieur
pareil pour les prothèses dentaires
filets sociaux d'écran sud pendant une
dizaine de secondes vérifier que la
respiration passe bien en approchons
votre joue de la bouche de la victime
pour sentir l'air qui en sort guettez
les bruits anormaux et profitez-en pour
surveiller visuellement que la poitrine
se soulève bien en rythme si la victime
porte des lunettes retirer lui et placer
délicatement ces gens dans laxe de son
corps placé son bras le plus proche de
vous à 90° c'est-à-dire à angle droit
puis son avant-bras également à angle
droit
la paume de la main vers le ciel ensuite
mettez votre paume contre la paume de
son autre main que vous placez contre
son oreille
approché la jambe opposée sous le genou
rapprocher le talon le plus proche de la
fesse
écartez vous un petit peu et fait
pivoter la victime vers vous retirer
votre main en laissant la sienne en
place et déplier la jambe du tout en la
plaçant à 90 degrés ouvrez la bouche de
la victime sans bouger sa tête
voilà elle est installée dans une
position stable qui lui permet de
respirer et d'évacuer les liquides
qu'elle a dans la bouche et sa colonne
vertébrale est toujours bien rester dans
l'âtre donc pas de risque d'avoir abîmé
sa moelle épinière
il vous reste plus qu'à surveiller sa
respiration et son état de conscience
jusqu'à l'arrivée des secours
d'ailleurs si personne les a prévenus
c'est le moment merci je viens tu m'as
sauvé ba a laissé bien peu de chose par
contre j'aime beaucoup ton slip on n'y
pense même pas voilà dtc c'est fini pour
aujourd'hui on se retrouve très vite
pour un nouveau geste qui sauve abonnez
vous pour pas rater ça en attendant
éviter les ennuis
prenez soin de vous et des autres et
portez vous